I read that you had this line that you
cannot be protected from being called an
[__] correct especially if you're an
[__]
well that's uh
but you don't have to be an [__] to
be called an [__] that's correct and
uh I think the internet has taught me
that well the internet is posed a
particular challenge to free speech
absolutist because of some of the stuff
that's on there is god-awful
but I have no different rule for freedom
of speech on the internet than I have uh
in newspapers or in lectures or in
classrooms or or conversations among
people what do you think about the
tension between freedom of speech and
freedom of reach as is uh kind of
sometimes termed so the internet really
challenges that aspect it allows the
speech to become viral and spread very
quickly to a very large number of people
but you know we've had we've had
Revolutions in um
in in the modalities of communication
after all newspapers were the first
challenge
um radio and television
posed A new challenge
the FCC tried
But ultimately gave up the attempt to
control
obscenity for example
um
and the Supreme Court has been pretty
close the one thing that liberal and
conservative Supreme Courts right now
we're in a conservative era due to Trump
nominations
um
during much of my life we were the
Warren Court it was uh WIlliam Mo
Douglas Brennan liberal Court
one thing they agree on is Free Speech
they don't agree on much else but they
do agree on free speech and I think the
reason is
that they recognize that well my group
is in the ascendants today but it may
not be tomorrow and I want to have
objective clear rules so that when I'm
in the minority I'm able to voice my
opinion
and so it's one of the few things that
both sides of the political Spectrum
agree on the only people who don't or
the the people way over on the right
that I call the fascists and the people
way over on the left who are the
Communists
um but with respect to most people in
this on the political Spectrum
Republicans Democrats socialists
Libertarians
um
they agree on the Primacy of free speech
because it protects them
when when protection is needed so to you
even on the internet
Free Speech absolutism should rule yes
nobody's gonna die remember death
threats are not law not protected
um nobody's gonna die
so people are going to be a little bit
insulted that's the price you pay for
living in a free society and it's a
small price in my view
um people some people don't have as
tough a hide as others well than develop
it um
yeah I hope everyone I don't mean to
sound cruel
but you know you're living in a free
Society develop a tough hide
so that's the cost of living in a free
Society there's a cost the thing is that
it can really hurt at scale to be Cyber
Bullied to be attacked for the ideas to
express or maybe ideas you didn't
Express but that uh somebody decided to
lie about you and uh use that to attack
you well first of all there are there
were so there were some exceptions to
the First Amendment
libel and slander is an exception
um
direct threats or an exception you know
if you if you say such and such I will
murder you that is not lawful
if you say that it's somebody
um if you say about somebody oh you know
um you beat your wife
um that that is not lawful if in fact
the person knows you don't beat your
wife
there are some limits the defamation is
one direct threats or another
um so it's not absolute this is not the
first amendment is not absolute but this
is it's more absolute than it is in any
other society and it's pretty near
absolute
um
for example fraud if you would sell
somebody a car and you say oh this is in
great running shape and in fact it's an
old jalopy and it's not going to make it
more than 10 miles
that's fraud that's not free speech
um so free speech is not absolute there
are these limits but they're very narrow
specific categories of limits
but uh this gray area here because while
legally you're not allowed to defame a
person
in the court of public opinion
especially with the aid of anonymity on
the internet
the rumors can spread
at scale thousands hundreds of thousands
of people can make up things about you
you have to defend yourself using more
speech we're we're big we're through
freedom of speech and we're big boys and
girls
um you have to defend yourself
um you know in in some societies if you
say something
um if you right now if you say something
nasty about Putin you'll end up in the
gulag
um if you say something nasty about
um Biden you end up in the New York
Times where would you rather be